Reality could be like an onion,
we don't know,
but it could be like an onion
to where you think, you know,
you're studying a layer of an onion and
then you peel it away and there's more
and you keep doing it.
And there's an infinite number
of layers with intelligence.
There's the same kind of component
to where we think we know we got it,
we figured out, we figured out how to
beat the human world champion to chess,
we solved intelligence, and then we
try the next thing. Wait a minute,
go was really difficult to solve as
a game. And then you say, okay, uh,
I've,
I came up when the game
of go was impossible for
artificial intelligence systems
to be and if not recently had been beaten
within the last like five years. Right.
And next last five years.
There's a lot of technical fascinating
things of why that victory is interesting
and important for artificial intelligence.
It requires creativity, correct?
It does not.
It just exhibits creativity.
So the technical aspects of why Alphago
from Google deep mind that that was the
designers and the builders of the system.
That was the victor.
They did a few very interesting
technical things where essentially you're
develop a neural network.
This is this type of artificial
intelligence system that
looks at a board of go
as a lot of elements on it is black and
white pieces and is able to tell you how
good is this situation and
how can I make it better?
And that idea,
so chess players can do this.
I'm not actually definitely over the game
of go is that can speak to I'm Russian,
so chest to us as romanticizes
the beautiful game. Uh,
I think that there you look at a board
and all your previous experiences,
all the things you've developed over tens
of years of practice and thinking you
get this instinct of what
is the right path to follow.
And that's exactly what the neural
network is doing. And some of the,
some of the paths it has come up with
are surprising to other world champions.
So in that sense it says,
well,
this thing's exhibiting creativity because
it's coming up with solutions that are
something that's outside the box.
Thinking from the perspective
of the human when why?
What do you differentiate between requires
creativity and exhibits creativity?
I think one because we don't really
understand what creativity is,
so it's almost,
yeah,
it's on the level of concepts such
as consciousness. For example,
the question which there's a lot of
thinking about whether creating something
intelligent requires consciousness,
acquire as for us to be
actual living beings,
aware of our own
existence in the same way.
Does doing something like
building an autonomous vehicle,
that's the area where I work in.
Does that require creativity?
Does that even requires something like
consciousness and self awareness? I mean,
I'm sure in La there's some degree of
creativity required to navigate traffic
and in that sense you start to think,
are there solutions that are
outside of the box and AI system?
You used to create it.
It's once you start to build it,
you realize that to us, humans, certain
things appear at creative, certain things,
dope.
Certain things we take for granted,
certain things we find beautiful and
certain things are like, yeah, yeah,
that's right. Well, there's
creativity in different levels, right?
There's creativity like to write
the stand was Stephen King novel,
and that requires creativity.
There's something about his,
he's creating these stories.
He's giving voices to these characters.
He's developing these scenarios and these
dramatic sequences in the book that's
going to get you really sucked in. That's,
that's almost undeniable creativity,
right? Is it? It's a,
he's imagining a world,
what is it always set in a New Hampshire,
Massachusetts, Maine, Maine is, right.
So he's imagining a world and imagine
the emotion of different levels
surrounding that world. Yeah.
That's, that's creative.
Although if there's a
few really good books,
including his own that
talks about writing. Yeah.
He's got a great book on writing
and it's actually called on writing.
If there's anyone who can write a book on
writing, it should be Stephen King. Uh,
I think Steven Pressfield,
I hope I'm not saying the war of art
and the war of art. Beautiful Book.
And I would say if,
from my recollection,
they don't necessarily talk
about creativity very much,
that it's really hard work of putting in
the hours of every day of just grinding
it out.
Well Pressfield talks about the muse.
Pressfield speaks of it
almost in like a strange,
mystical, mystical sort of
connection to the unknown.
Cause he,
he almost,
I'm not even exactly sure if he
believes in the muse, but he, he,
I think if I could put words in his
mouth, I have met him. He's a great guy.
He was on the podcast once.
I think the way he treats it as deaf,
if you decide the music is real and you
show up every day and you write as if
the Muse is real, you get the benefits
of the muse being real. That's right.
Whether or not there's actually a muse
that's giving you these wonderful ideas,
and what is the muse? So I think of
artificial intelligence the same way.
There's a quote by, uh, Pamela, uh,
McCormack from 1979 book
that I really like. Uh,
she talks about the history
of artificial intelligence.
Ai began with an ancient
wish to forge the gods.
And to me, God's broadly
speaking or religions represents,
it's kind of like the muse.
It represents the limits of possibility,
the limits of our imagination.
So it's this thing that we don't
quite understand that is the muse,
that is God, this us,
us chimps are very narrow in our ability
to perceive and understand the world.
And there's clearly a much bigger,
beautiful,
mysterious world out there and God
or the Muse represents that world.
And for many people, I think throughout
history and especially in the,
in the past set of a hundred years,
artificial intelligence has become to
represent that a little bit to the thing
which we don't understand and we crave.
We're both terrified and we crave in
creating this thing that has greater,
that is able to understand the world
better than us. And that in that sense,
artificial intelligence is the desire
to create the muse is this other,
this imaginary thing.
And I think that one of
the beautiful things,
if you talk about everybody from y'all,
I musta Sam Harris to all the
people thinking about this,
is that there's a mix of fear
of that, of, of that unknown,
of creating that unknown and an excitement
for it because there's something in
human nature, the desires creating
that. Because like I said,
creating is how you understand.
Hmm.
Did you initially study biology?
Did you study the actual
development of the mind or what,
what is known about the,
the evolution of the human mind and
the of the human mind? Yeah. Uh,
so my path is different as it's the same
for a lot of computer scientists and
roboticists is we ignore biology,
neuroscience, the physiology,
anatomy of our own bodies.
And there's a lot of beliefs now that
you should really study biology and he
should study neuroscience.
You should study your own
brain, the actual chemistry,
what's happening, what is actually,
how are the neurons are interconnected,
all the different kinds
of systems in there.
So that is a little bit of a blind
spot or it's a big blind spot.
But the problem is,
so I started with more philosophy
almost. It's where, um,
if you think Sam Harris is
the last couple of years,
it started kind of thinking about
artificial intelligence and he,
he has a back on, you know, science,
but he's also a philosopher.
And I started there by reading
[inaudible] or dusty yefsky thinking,
what is,
what is intelligence?
What is human morality? Uh, will, uh,
so all of these concepts give you the
context for which you can then start
studying these problems.
And then I said, there's a,
there's a magic that happens when
you build a robot that drives around.
I mean, your father. Um, uh, I
would like to be, but I'm not yet.
Uh, there's a creation aspect.
That's wonderful. That's incredible.
It's for me, I don't have any
children at the moment, but the,
the act of creating a robot where you
programmed it and it moves around and it's
census. The world is, this
is, is a, is a magical moment.